[Music]
oh
what's up hey andrew
how's it going
no come on let's go i got another food
adventure for us what are we eating
pasta
all right yeah that's right this guy
right here that's my boy
let's go this is wet
now i'm wet pasta baby we are on our way
to eat three of the best pastas in los
angeles at three drastically different
price points to find out which one is
the most worth it at its price worth it
the last spot we're going to i don't
know if you're ready for it i've had 300
steak 130 pizza i think i'm ready for
pasta i have a feeling i know what the
highest one is going to be you ain't
ready you weren't born ready is it
truffle though
don't worry about it man we're on our
way right now to pasta sisters can i go
this way no no no no
not enter
where oh yeah was it one way you can go
down there dang it guys you start seeing
cars come towards us
just stop
i'm francesco i'm owner of pasta sister
with my mother paola we decided to open
this place because we thought in los
angeles there are many great places but
very little make fresh pasta low prices
like we do we start early in the morning
making the pasta we make it with italian
flour because not all the flowers make
good pasta and not all the flour makes
it yellow and beautiful to stay for
seven days like our pasta does you guys
are not sisters obviously i don't see
any sisters here so they say i'm the
prettiest one
my mom and her sister were here my
sister georgia works in the front with
us today we're gonna prepare for you the
italian arabiata our lightly spicy
tomato sauce put olive oil chili flakes
some garlic oil when the pasta is ready
you put the tomato sauce and put the
parsley it's the last ingredient
and the pasta is done
wow this tastes like the adult version
of repair are we gonna eat off the same
plate we got a lot of pasta to eat today
let's just avoid any lady in the [ __ ]
type situation here
great i hated that
it's very good pasta that was intense
every noodle is just blanketed in sauce
i also get that sense that i'm in like
his mama's kitchen in italy
never been italy before but we're gonna
prepare also the gnocchi with the
porcini mushroom and cream sauce we use
the porcini that we made in the morning
adding some cream everything made from
scrunch fresh gnocchi he described this
as pillows everything that has ever been
described as a pillow has been great
it's like the ultimate pillow fight for
my mouth
holy smother so is gnocchi pasta no it's
a kind of pasta but we don't call it
pasta it's made with potato flour these
are easily the best gnocchi i've ever
had
oh man we haven't had any of this bread
yet look how easy it is to pull apart no
effort at all it's like mama's best
these are all my mom's best recipes but
from our secret menu we have the
spaghetti bottarga with the dry fish
eggs from mallet we're gonna definitely
get that yeah buddy yeah you know when
you've been a good boy and your mom just
like gives you an extra treat
i mean this flavor is insane it tastes
like it's covered in cheese that's how
rich it is why is it on the secret menu
though it's like why they don't tell us
the the alien exists
my stomach is full but my heart is full
i'm not going to say anything that dumb
so let's just go
talk about the sisters though i mean not
in that way
it's like a neighborhood deli that also
makes the best pasta you've ever had
they are unapologetic about being
themselves and they don't even have a
bathroom speaking of which we got to get
to the next place asap
costa fact
of course costa fact
according to the international pasta
organization how many different shapes
of pasta are produced throughout the
world there's an international pasta
organization 100
600
whoa
don't did you cheat
you cheated no i didn't there's more
than 600 kinds yes really wowza so right
now we're on our way to osteria mama
what do you say excuse me in uh italian
scoozy no it's not
really
excuse me papa pasta there you go do i
sound remotely at all correct
this is australia mamma my name is
filippo gortivo i'm the owner you know
we opened this restaurant i give to my
mother that's why mama is the name this
is our whole the dough you know we have
flour from italy it's a very delicate
double zero flour and you can be too
fast you can be too slow and that's why
it has to be handmade that's why we do
every handmade because we like to keep
control of that process then we let the
pasta dry for a while and then he's
ready what are you going to be serving
us today today we try two pasta the
first dish we're going to prepare is the
blackswooding biggoly with the bottarga
and shrimp but first we add cherry
tomatoes we shave the botarga and as
always white wine what makes really good
pasta for you perfect pasta for me is
when the noodles combine with the sauce
that's the flavor of the exposure of
your mouth round two course one begoli
neri
i do have a second stomach i just like
move it in place when i need it i always
have my second stomach engaged
cheers
mmm
this is really special it was true what
he said
the noodles sucked in all the flavoring
here this is a flavor explosion and then
when it's in your mouth
[Music]
the second dish for you guys is going to
be the green spinach papardelle in a
dark regular it's extra virgin olive oil
it's a little bit of garlic the ground
ducks are really pretty cooked so you
add a little bit of cherry tomatoes
white wine you know we're italian so we
like to put wine everywhere and what
we're trying to give it's like a little
jump in italy i talked before about
explosion in your mouth and the wine is
a part of it it reminds me of me and
andrew we're two very imperfect people
but together perfect explosion
in the world
sure
is that wine luxurious
that has a deep smell how deep does it
smell kind of like your deep voice can
we get to the boss cheers
yeah
a lot of flavor control it to your mouth
please uncontainable you know whatever
explosion no it's not even explosion
anymore it's like dynamite that is an
explosion
hey it's the first time i made that
sucking noise on this shred today this
pasta is not just more expensive you are
getting more there you're getting that
meat sauce you're getting that complete
fish dish and it's still simple if one
of us is pasta and one of us has sauce
who's pasta who's sauce say who you
think you are on three one two three
pasta
do you like that
the squid ink pasta never had a noodle
like that it was very imperfect and
craggly but it was also a thick strand i
think the best dish we had so far was
the duck ragu one fast effect some of
the earliest recorded reports of eating
noodles come from china as early as 5000
bc
all righty the last place the final spot
we're going to get some truffle pasta i
knew i called it but this is gonna be
different they're gonna be lighting a
wheel of parmesan on fire it's dinner
and a show i am so excited because i
freaking love white truffles do your
pasta dance
cut that out
pasta
my name is jeremy i'm one of the
executive chef at the petit paris we're
in a french restaurant in los angeles
tonight we're gonna make the truffle
pasta we make it for 100 with the white
truffle we're gonna flame a world cheese
parmesan with cognac and we're gonna
roll all the pasta together and what
sort of noodle are you making there do
you make that here no no not an italian
restaurant
so it's an italian dish but you're
putting a french spin on it yes with a
lot of pasta in france excited yeah
ready for a shower let's go in the
kitchen let's go so i'm gonna add little
bit of olive oil some shallots we need
to roast it that is the white truffle
yes i sliced little bits just to have
more flavor in the pasta a little bit of
cream little bit of parmesan chocolate
we're gonna add the pasta and now we are
ready to flank
first of all with the cheese i'm gonna
scrap little bit of parmesan the cognac
it's hot
let's go
[Music]
you can play with the fire here you go
andrew
just be careful
we have the pasta
we're going to mix everything together
you put in a plate and after you shave
some fresh truffle from the customer
thank you so much chef to end the day we
have the 100 flambeed white truffle
pasta dish are you prepared i've had
five pastas today i think i'm as
prepared as i'll ever be this is the
first time that some
theatrics have been added to our dining
experience are you gonna have any wine
i'm gonna have a taste
this is splendid i need a moment to
prepare myself to eat it so if you want
to take a bite first i derive pleasure
from watching people eat i don't like
that you're just watching me
damn it
you better get in here i feel like
camera guy should have some before i
should
[Music]
are you gonna have any of this because
it's really good and i have no
self-control okay i'm gonna take a bite
how's it going
disappointed
no i don't think so wow
white truffle is indescribable and we
talked about flavor explosions today
this is the most intense flavor flavor
explosion i just live life
one flavor explosion at a time you more
so do it just like a bunch of the time
you never stop eating you feel um like
our french investment cemented
[Music]
i feel like my stomach has been cemented
with about two pounds of pasta just
admit it
i admit nothing
we just ate six different pasta dishes
in one day well you know what's coming
which pasta was the most worth it i do
believe that 100 pasta it was worth the
money you got to interact with the chef
the fact that he flom baited yeah
it's a 35 burp right there but to me
that wasn't the most worth it at its
price osteria mama you get the handmade
pasta married with a great sauce no
question it's worth it my worth at
winner today hands down goes to pop
assistant yeah i also pick pasta sisters
wowza a25 for authentic italian cuisine
straight from their handmade pasta to my
mouth
unbelievable they had the most
incredible gnocchi i've ever had i guess
we should really ask bianchi what he
thinks considering he is the most
italian person in his car he grew up in
ohio
oh me too
pasta lavista
no
i love it when you call me big pasta
[Music]
i just remembered that one oh yes